[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
george campbell ramsey personality and i
are here to answer your questions this
hour all about your careers all about
your relationships your money your life
it all happens right here on the ramsay
show it's a free call and some say the
advice is worth exactly what you pay for
it the phone number is triple eight
eight two five five
two two five if you don't know george's
name off the top of your head i don't
know where you've been but he's the host
of the fine print podcast here at on
ramsay networks which is a uh the first
season is now in the books you can
listen to the whole season binge it and
it's all about what happens in the fine
print and that everybody knows the fine
prints what gets you so george is going
to tell you where to uh not be gotten
meantime we're here to help you phone
number triple eight eight two five five
two two five sarah's in trenton new
jersey hi sarah welcome to the ramsay
show
hi how are you better than i deserve
what's up
so i'm calling to see what you think
about
us selling our rental property we have a
condo that when we moved from the condo
to our house we couldn't get out from
under the condo because we were upside
down so we rented it we now have a
section 8 renter so we get
direct deposit from the state of new
jersey every month
so that's been reliable um but we're
trying to chip away at our debt and we
have a big
big debt right now um
so now there's equity in it get out of
the condo and now you can sell it for
money um there is right now yeah we
could make like 30 000. okay all right
but we could also be out of debt still
within a few years without selling it
yeah but you didn't you didn't start
this condo thing to be a landlord you
started it because you got stuck in it
right yeah
so here's the thing to have someone else
paying a mortgage yeah but they don't i
mean the section 8 pays you but you have
to go there and manage make sure you
don't tear the building down
i've had section 8 property i mean the
the payment is consistent
and the tenants some of them are the
worst in the world and some of them are
the best people in the world
uh we have one of the best well so far
yeah i mean yeah like i said i've had
both i've had them where i had to go
over there and explain to them we don't
do drugs and turn tricks right so um
not not in property that i own so i mean
you have to have these conversations
it's real and then i've had them that
are they're just the sweetest nicest
people in the world that um are getting
some help right now and turning their
lives around i've had both so anyway all
that to say this george and i use a
process we use it at ramsey here all the
time called a sunk cost analysis and
basically that means reverse engineer
the situation
so let's do it like this let's pretend
that uh you had thirty thousand dollars
less debt
and you didn't have the condo
which is what would happen if you sold
the condo right
right
would you go borrow money
thirty thousand dollars of other debt
to buy this condo
today
in this situation
no not in a million years
so it tells you what today
if you wouldn't do it over don't keep it
because every day you keep it you did it
over again
that make any sense
you sure i'm saying yeah sarah how how
fast would this speed up the process for
you guys if you sold it how much debt do
you have
um we have about 120 000
without the condo without the condo okay
yeah with the condoms you said you'd
make 30 000 profit
if you sold well yes we sold it right
now we talked to a realtor we'd make
around 30 000. okay well that's a good
chunk man it's a quarter your debt gone
what what type of debt do you have
that 120
um forty five thousand student loans
thirty thousand is in our two vehicles
and what's your household income
um about 189 000. very good okay okay we
got a good shovel here i'm wondering if
those cars are worth a pretty penny in
this market and you can sell those and
speed up this process
i mean i don't know about you but i want
to get our debt as fast as possible
could you sell one of them yeah well
that's what's making us think about
selling the condo is to not sell the car
to keep the vehicles
yeah i wouldn't i would sell the condo
before the cars sure okay i'm selling
the condo for sure you're gonna be 189
000 with zero debt in two years and you
can save up money and buy you a rental
later
and i suspect you would buy a different
rental
um no i mean we have a great condo in a
great location and we just happen to get
set up with a great sectioning
renter
um
be careful because you might you don't
don't be the person who dropped one
quarter into the slot machine and think
it works every time
okay i'm just telling you i've had a lot
of renters over the years i'm i'm a
landlord i've got a bunch of property
and it just doesn't always work that way
this idea that the renter is going to
pay your payments it's just a bunch of
crap okay you pay the payments and the
renter gives you some money we hope
and in section 8 case the government's
giving the money so the payment is
guaranteed but i'm telling you there's
uh
do not let the world that you're sitting
in today influence that you can do it if
you want to do it but you better do it
with your eyes wide open so anyway
doesn't matter today today i'm selling
the condo yeah it's gone
andrea is with us in san diego hi andrea
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave thank you for taking my call
sure what's up um
okay so my dad died 37 years ago and my
mom started he left properties and
assets so my mom um we're three kids
now in the age of 50 around 50. so my
mom started managing
properties then does she not did your
mom own them at that time
um when your dad died did he leave all
the property to your mom
uh
okay we're talking about six properties
two are jointly owned with my brothers
my mom um in argentina when the spouse
dies 50
is for it's complicated dave 50 uh to my
mom and the the other 50 belongs to the
three of us two properties are like that
okay and then
two were in an llc um
which are
about to be
um to put in a title for my brothers my
two brothers
they live in argentina i live here in
the us right so
the properties are in argentina
correct
so
uh okay so my mother started managing
them first then my youngest brother
started managing and putting most of the
money in his pocket
then in one of my trips
that was raised to me by my
middle brother
and they both started managing
the properties
pocketing most of the money themselves
right i was just getting um whatever
they they thought was fair
um now that years have passed i have
grown children i started looking into
numbers and things like that and i'm
realizing that they have been giving me
between
55 15 and 25 of what was supposed to
uh my part right
so i would like i'm trying to divide
things to make things clear transparent
but they are reluctant they are lashing
out
one has completely shut down he doesn't
take my phone calls
and um
so
and my mom
i mean in a way she's a little bit
biased right i mean she loves the three
of us but in a way she's a little bit
biased because she's chauvinistic you
know that's the way she was raised yeah
i'll tell you what you hang on when we
come back from this break we'll hear the
rest of this sordid story
and
give you an opinion on it we're an
expert on our opinions that's right this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest-serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many
more verses
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host thank you for joining us america
we're so glad you're here we're talking
with andrea in san diego she's got
brothers sisters brothers and her mother
uh with managing inherited property that
she's a partial owner of in argentina
they've been paying her what they wanted
to pay her over the years and she just
looked up the other day decided to do
some math after 36 years and discovered
that she's not getting her fair share
now she's trying to separate this and
get clarity on it and she's getting a
lot of pushback is that a fair summary
of what you told us so far andrea
yes
okay so what are you going to do
that's my question to you uh and also
let's add that they have lived rent free
for
one at least 18 years and the other one
seven years rent free plus receiving all
the income from the other properties
right yeah and my mom insists on me
being nice andrea be nice be nice to
them
be nice
means not telling them i mean i am
frustrated being nice means getting
screwed by your brothers
in a way yes no definitely they've been
screwing you over for years is what you
just told us
decades yes they've been messing you
over for a long time and that's her
definition of being nice no thanks mom
i'll pass on being nice
it's not being nice that's being a
victim
i don't want to be a victim well you are
a victim
but you you know and if you're going to
con either going to continue to be one
or you're not it's up to you
so you've got a couple of options here
as far as actually three
one
you just keep going like you are
and be nice
yeah no okay
the other one is you can just
sign over all the property to them
and say good luck with it boys i'm done
with y'all i don't want any more money i
don't want anything else to do with any
of you you've messed me over so bad
here's the deed to everything i'm just
going to walk away from this the family
dysfunction is not worth whatever the
assets are i'm through with you and just
sign it over to them which by the way is
not a really bad idea
that's not a bad idea at all it's not
the idea you were expecting me to give
you
and of course the third option is to use
the argentine in courts to settle this
if your brothers don't come to the table
peacefully and start signing over
properties to you
yeah
i think they're blind they are blind by
rage and fear i don't care um
yeah
you get it they they have 10 days
or they have 30 days from the time i
call them
regardless of all their screwed up
dysfunctions and machoism or whatever it
is they're dealing with
to you have 30 days for us to work this
out if you do not work this out by this
date
my attorney will begin the process in
the argentinian courts of suing all of
your pants off
okay and by the way the attorneys are
going to get all the money and the
family's going to end up with nothing
that's how this always works because
that's how attorneys work
yes so andrea what was the agreement up
front 36 37 years ago that you would get
a third
i was uh when my dad died i was 14 years
old i was a kid so
i mean i had no agreement right
now there was a will there was a there
was a direction
he said it split between the estate was
supposed to be
no there was no wheel
we were talking about six properties two
were in an llc two were
in our name jointly on my two brothers
and i so two are like that and two are
in a succession right
uh they're supposed to be
uh in our name i mean 50 for my mom i'm
50 for three of us
and you said you're getting about 15 to
20 what would you think would be fair
what is the mathematically correct
amount to get
um
a year
well percentage-wise you said you're
getting 15 to 20. you're saying you
should be getting 33.
i'm i'm saying 15 20 uh 25 percent of
the uh 33 that i should get yeah you
gotta you got you got a tiny fraction of
what you should be getting is what
you're trying to say all right so here's
the thing
they you have lost trust in them
because they've stolen from you
yes
and so you either need to walk away from
them
or you need to separate the properties
and if they don't do that
with reasonableness and voluntarily will
have a judge make them do that
okay
i don't know anything about argentine in
law or courts
in the u.s this is a partnership a
general partnership that you're going
before civil court and asking the judge
to force the disillusionment of the
partnership which means they either buy
you out or they sell the property and
everybody gets their section everybody
gets their part
okay you know force the disillusionment
of the partnership because you no longer
trust your partners who sadly are your
own brothers
funded emotionally by your mother who is
an enabler
yes yes
that's true yeah and so it's a sad thing
i'm so sorry it breaks your heart and
honestly i i don't know what is your
financial situation how wealthy are you
i'm doing well what would as well got 10
million dollars or two dollars no no no
no no no uh in about less than 10 years
we're going to pay off my house in san
diego california and we have another if
you never got another dime from this
would it really affect your life
no
not really but
um
i mean i feel i'm not standing up for my
own family at this point i know you're
not uh i know you're not but let me just
tell you not much i don't think you're
going to fix your family
i think when this is all said and done
they're all still going to be pissed
don't you
probably yeah so you're not going to get
there
there's not going to be a there's not a
version of this story where everybody
gets together and smiles
and makes a big meal and is so glad to
see each other again
there's that version of this story does
not exist
that's not going to happen is it
if you talk them into it and they did
you your portion you're still going to
feel badly towards them for stealing
from you and they're still going to feel
like you force them into doing something
they didn't want to do if you sue them
we know that they're going to feel that
way and you're no you're going to feel
that way and now everybody's writing
lawyers checks too
so it's there's not a version of this
story where everybody gets back together
and is all happy again
yeah too much misbehavior under the
bridge
i wish it would happen but i don't think
it's going to happen realistically so
you just got to decide what you want to
do
i think you need to seriously consider
from from your standpoint uh the idea of
just deeding it over to them
and just walking away
i don't want to do that okay
all right well you got to fight then
then you're going to you're getting
ready to stir up a ruckus kiddo
that's not an argentina phrase that's a
hillbilly phrase you're gonna you're
gonna stir up a ruckus i don't know how
you say that in spanish but you're about
to stir i'd love to hear it it'd
probably sound really cool
but this whole thing is just dripping
with resentment on either side and so
everybody's mad and hurt it's just
poisoning yourself at some point and
there's a lot
there's a lot of times in these
situations and it because even her
giving him them the property is not
gonna make them happy or her happy
there's not a version not an option that
i see on the table where everyone plays
patty cake and kissy face after this is
done
they're just not going to this has gone
on too long
mom is too screwed up the brothers are
too big of crooks and she's too pissed
about it yeah and you're talking
international and so there's not you
can't just she's international pissed
this is a different level different
level
i'm not messing with argentina man
this is a tough situation she's gonna
have to get a backbone here and so
regardless of
the country this illustrates why you
need a will
and why you need to read the will while
you're alive
and tell everyone what's going to happen
if everybody's going to be mad after
you're gone go ahead do it while you're
live just make them mad now
go ahead and show them now this is
what's gonna happen
you're doing cocaine so we're leaving
you nothing okay and you can just be
pissed about that now okay go ahead and
be mad about it or you're dysfunctional
and you're disconnected from the family
and so we're not leaving you anything
let's go ahead and clear the air on that
when i pass if i'm the dad what i don't
want is for my kids to bicker and fight
for the rest of their lives because of
what i left them as a blessing each of
them arguing incorrectly what dad's will
was when he had a will we all have our
own interpretation no yeah daddy always
said i don't give a let me tell you what
daddy always said daddy always read the
will once a year and said this is what
it is baby mama always said this is what
it is baby you need to have a reading of
the will while you're alive
to be able to call it a will what is my
will
upon my death my will for you is
that you get this and you get this
that's what the will means we say to be
unclear is to be unkind and this is what
it is testament your testament as to
what you want to have happen we'll go
ahead and cover it while you're alive
and write it down in a legal document
and everyone then is on the same page
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host in the lobby of ramsey solutions
on the debt free stage sean and cassie
are with us hey guys how are you we're
good how are you welcome welcome where
do you guys live
oklahoma all right good good to have you
guys how much debt have you paid off um
forty three thousand dollars whoa
how long did that take uh five years and
ten months good for you
and your range of income during that
time um we started out about 75
at the peak um we made it up to 180 and
then when coveted and new careers happen
we're back down about 75. oh okay wow
what do y'all do for a living um so
through the debt payoff uh i was a tire
builder for michelin
i was a tar builder as well um i now
work for a pool cleaning service company
i've been there about five months and
actually started a brand new job on
monday as a surgical tech oh wow cool
cool so no more work at the at the tire
place yeah no more shift work we get to
be home every night with our babies
i'll take it i'll take it okay five
years and 10 months 243 000 how old are
you guys
32 and i'm 31 i'll be 32 in march wow
i'm gonna guess and say you paid off
your house yes sir yes
sir looking at weird people man so you
did this from 27 to 32 years old you pay
off everything house and everything 243
000 what's the house worth high in about
240 is what we're being told
how does it feel it's amazing that's
great you guys are amazing you're so
young and so rich
[Laughter]
so what causes 27 year olds to just go
full throttle on this thing so
cassie had actually kind of been
mentioning some stories about people
getting out of debt and i thought oh
that's kind of neat but at the time i
struggled with our income because it was
kind of low she would tell me stories of
people that made 240 000 a year and
getting out of debt like well you
shouldn't have been in debt in the first
place
so she had been hinting at this thing
but at the same time which is what
people that make 40 say about you making
75 by the way but anyway
never ends and but the thing is we were
actually
about a month away from having our first
little girl and i was in a place where i
was really struggling with understanding
what is
what is the purpose of all this i was in
a job that was basically dead end that
was requiring more hours without more
pay but we were also trying to be
involved in ministry
and because of our job
we were having a hard time being able to
put the work into the ministry and
um
and i'm just in a place where i'm just
frustrated i'm frustrated because i
don't understand life and then i've got
this little girl who's going to look up
to me one day and like hey dad what does
all this mean and i don't have an answer
and i'm frustrated in this idea of
living paycheck to paycheck for the rest
of my life
why this is pointless and then so i
my peak frustration i'm working late one
day my radio show ends and on comes dave
ramsey and he starts talking about the
baby steps and just almost just right
out of the gate you just start listening
to baby steps and start talking about
the snowball and i'm like oh this is
amazing and what's funny is about three
months before that someone had actually
sent us financial peace university i had
never heard of it never sent it seen it
it came from a really weird source which
is a
odd story so i didn't to be honest when
i first saw it i was like this kind of
looks like a get rich quick scheme and
it does right so i just i blew it off
she was all about it but i was like i
blew it off well i come home and i'm
like hey we're going to do this she goes
oh that's a great idea i'm glad you
thought of it
and then about two weeks later i'm
listening to the radio show and i hear
my second debt-free scream and it was a
couple of nurses they had about a 170
000 income but they paid off their house
and you asked them how long did that
take you went and they said six years
and you went yep our average family pays
off their home in about seven years and
i remember immediately coming well i
don't think we can do that but i'm i'm
still excited about the program well i
start doing the math
and then just that light bulb goes off
we can pay our house off in seven years
and then i instantly connected that with
my little girl and i was like
we could have our pet house paid for by
the time she's seven years old and that
was like a shotgun blast to my chest
that i still get to this day whoa yes i
like it
that's incredible i like it yeah
okay and so uh cassie's coming along the
whole time saying oh good idea
jesus
yeah i'm so glad you're enthused
yeah no i mean it probably wasn't that
sarcastic but not quite not quite okay
all right he's being nice so you get
about the business of knocking out your
other debts you walk through the whole
baby steps
you're 32 years old you have a 250 000
home that is paid for
and you've been funding your retirement
all along
as well very good very good so how much
is in your nest egg it's a little low
but it's um sitting around at about a
hundred
i think that's not low you're 32
compared
i think you're going to be worth tens of
millions of dollars that's the goal
that's our goal yeah you guys well on
your way to baby step millionaire very
very quickly it's going to come so fast
now that you got this done and now that
you're in control of this whole subject
and here's the other thing i think what
you pointed out so beautifully sean is
that
how much you believe and why you believe
that it'll work
affects whether or not you freaking do
it
you know and it's like i can't do that
people like that i can't do that i can't
do that wait a minute oh my god i can do
that
it changes everything yeah and it took
math for you it definitely helps he is
the nerd yeah if we do that he is the
nerd that definitely helps wow yeah
math
numbers give me hope
i mean i get hope from numbers when i
lay them out and it shows me that the
thing can be done you know well we can
do that really oh here's how oh look at
that oh my gosh yeah well way to go you
guys way to go very very cool okay now
that you're there
you've got people listening maybe for
the first time ever maybe this is their
first debt free scream they're watching
or they're listening
uh they're watching on youtube or
listening somewhere on a podcast or on
the radio
um you're 32 the paid for house that is
very weird you are weird people without
a doubt because normal's broke
normal's out of control normal sally mae
has her own bedroom because she's been
with us so long and you're 100
free tell people what the key to getting
out of debt is what do you guys say that
you did that caused this to happen
um i definitely think um the budget for
me was you know we could see exactly how
much and we're like oh we spent 200
eating out this time when we could have
paid 150 and went out one time to eat
you know um
that and just
the uh
just being on the same page like
where do we want to be in five years
from now
for me your why has to be louder than
your excuses
oh that's tweetable mike
back when back when twitter mattered
that show oh my gosh that shotgun to my
chest uh i'd think about it constantly
and every time it had the same effect
say it again for us you're why
your why has to be louder than your
excuses oh man and you've you've got
that that little girl and you've got the
girl dad shirt on i can tell how proud
you are and the legacy that you want to
leave for that girl man that changes
things
you're willing to make sacrifices aren't
you yes sir when you get that face
staring back at you and you want
different for her
we actually have two little girls oh my
goodness that's incredible that's
amazing yeah the loud part is excellent
i like the loud yeah your why has to be
louder than your excuses because the
excuses are pretty loud yeah and there
actually has to be louder than the
excuses of your broke friends telling
you you can't do it's exactly right
yeah you can't do that and people like
us didn't do that yeah my critics are
actually um some of my favorite people
in this journey because when it's three
o'clock in the morning your hands hurt
your bones hurt and you're staring at
this stupid tire and you're like i'm
just i'm done i don't i don't want to
work this hard i don't want to be here
and then i'd hear that voice of the
critic that says you know why this is a
stupid idea or you can't do this and all
of a sudden
i've got a new burst of energy it's like
nope i'm not going to give you the
satisfaction of giving me that i told
you so yeah no we have to have that toby
keith moment how you like me now
you know yeah i love it well done you
guys
all right bring the kiddos in let's
introduce them what are the ages and get
out of the girls and their names um
riley is six
and parker will be one in just a couple
of weeks all right way to go guys very
cool we've got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you number one
bestseller and we know that'll be the
next chapter in your story so way to go
guys you're rock stars man you're
amazing it's an honor to speak with you
great great
thoughts great lines great everything
here very very well done
all right it's shawn and cassie riley
and parker from ardmore oklahoma 32
years old with a paid for house and
everything 243 000 paid off five years
and 10 months making 75 to 180 to 75.
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream you ready ready three two one
[Applause]
george you know how rich they're going
to be unbelievable oh
my goodness
and millions and millions
that's a family tree that's changed
sharp couple this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hey just a reminder
we have uh
our show done on the glass you know the
lobby of our ramsey solutions
headquarters and so if you visit the
headquarters there's all kinds of things
to do here and and bookstore and there's
a a wonderful coffee shop with homemade
cookies all of that is complimentary
free in other words
you can hang out watch the show uh which
sometimes is like watching ugly paint
dry but sometimes it's entertaining too
so
uh we'd love to have you there's usually
50 to 100 people out here hanging out
and depending on the time of year the
time of day
season and all that kind of stuff but uh
plenty of room and uh we'd love to have
you come and hang out with us the
lobby's beautiful and the headquarters
is something to see and a lot of you
while you're on your journey can uh you
get inspiration mid-journey from seeing
other people do their debt free screams
seeing other people in the lobby just
having conversations we know of many
people who met watching the show from
different cities and maintain contact
it's incredible as i was hosting the
video channel years ago i got to meet so
many people in the lobby and just hear
their stories and you know whoever's
hosting that day they'll go out there
twice an hour so it's a great time to
meet folks get your book signed you get
an awesome ramsay show mug on your way
out as well and so there's a lot a lot
of perks of it and nashville is not the
worst place to visit make a weekend out
of it no i mean downtown's a bit of a
redneck riviera i'm not going there i
mean redneck mardi gras actually met
redneck mardi gras it's like out of
control yeah but it's fun it's fun to
watch if you like watching drunk people
do crazy things there's a lot of good
people watching so um there's some good
but if you entertain clowns you join the
circus so just be careful down there
don't get don't become part of it
it's a lot of fun though and there's a
lot of fun things to do here that aren't
that so uh come visit us in nashville
franklin we're just south of nashville
in a wonderful town called franklin
tennessee it's an old civil war town and
uh just picturesque the downtown area
there's worth walking around and it's a
walking area beautiful beautiful there
you can throw a rock and hit a few cows
just from here it's amazing
yeah from from the building not from
france sure yeah there's no there's no
cows in downtown franklin just just to
clarify
but um the mayor's gonna get really
upset i don't want him upset with me
he's gonna be upset you're messing up
his tourism right now okay folks married
folks listen up imagine never having
another money argument with your spouse
imagine what it would feel like how much
better your marriage would be what about
your whole family get on the same page
well let me tell you what happens when
you go through financial peace
university and you're married you do it
together
it changes everything you learn how to
budget together
you're on the same page
and you often hear people say that when
they're doing their debt-free screams
they follow a proven money plan there's
no reason to fight we have a shared goal
a shared dream our last debt free
screamer said that right
it can be done to join a financial peace
university class and even get a free
trial
just visit ramseysolutions.com
fpu ramseysolutions.com
our question today comes from blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings they got free samples
free shipping new promos all the time
it's a great company they will take
great care of you for your window blinds
always use the promo code the magic word
ramsey
today's question comes from jason in
alabama he says my wife and i recently
paid off all credit cards and student
loans totaling 32 thousand dollars i'm a
finance manager for a car dealership and
one of the perks of my job is that i can
buy new and used vehicles for great
prices we have two auto loans of 40k and
50k we typically keep a vehicle for a
short period of time and then sell the
vehicle to claim the retail profits
we've always made more than we've paid
on or for the vehicle i'm new to your
show and i need you to tell me if i'm
being irresponsible or is my ability to
buy and sell for profits on vehicles a
quote unique position to use to my
advantage i'm aware that i'm likely to
get the rough talk for having dumb debt
and maybe that is what i need
that's interesting well at least he's
self-aware that helps he's dave aware
dave aware that's a whole new level of
self-awareness
wow interesting situation here so
they're 90 000 in debt but he's saying
well dave i'm just flipping i'm just
flip it's like flipping houses what's
wrong with that
[Music]
very interesting
i i can tell you there's there's better
ways to make money uh than on these
depreciating assets and the fact that
he's a finance manager for a car
dealership tells me that he is used to
going into debt helping people go into
debt and he he thinks he's above the
system because he's figured it out he's
making money off the system
but i don't think that will last long
and i i if i'm in his position i'm not
doing it but that's one man's opinion
who does not like debt
yeah well i mean obviously we're going
to tell you not to do debt son
here's the thing you're not calculating
you have over calculated the profits and
under calculated the risks
that's what you've done
and time will prove me to be true when
you get your freaking head taken off
and i don't know what form it'll take it
could be a pandemic it could be you just
lose your job
and now you got 90 000 cars
debt
that's scary now are you buying cars and
making a profit on them i don't doubt
that at all i think that's very possible
lots of people around the car business
do that especially right now
um it's very possible to do that
so um but but we're not going to use
debt to finance that
if you're asking dave ramsey and george
campbell
because we don't like the risk
associated with it put your family in
peril for the few dollars that you're
making on it and yes you're right you
have rationalized your butt off son i
mean you've figured out every way that
this works in no way that it doesn't
work
and the you know that's what i mean by
your risk meter is not working
so
the uh the deal so if he wants to do
this pay cash for the car then flip it
you keep all the profits absolutely so i
would i would get rid of these and i
would save up money and buy a car for
cash that i can flip and if you want to
roll in and out of cars with cash
and make a profit on them that's cool
let me tell you what will happen when
you do that you're going to do fewer
deals
because when you buy something with
borrowed money
you do not analyze it as careful because
it doesn't feel real
when you're buying it with your money
out of your savings account it's
different it's like oh
i'm not sure about this
oh
and you have it's a different feeling
right and so what amounts to is you're
emotionally accepting the risk when you
pay cash for it yeah and when you when
you borrow money into anything you don't
think about it as much
it's too easy quote easy payments it's
easy to purchase press hard with that
pin as you're signing there's three
copies you have to get through all the
carbon i mean that's the way you're
thinking it's the only stress involved
and when this market calms down there
may not be much profits to be had at
that point i think if you buy a fifty
thousand dollar car for forty thousand
you're probably always going to be able
to turn it for for a ten thousand a
profit i mean you know and the market's
not gonna suddenly change and catch you
there i'm more afraid of a major change
in something else where just people quit
buying cars all of a sudden for some
reason i mean like i mean pandemic is an
extreme example i don't think we're
going to see that again i hope we don't
i've never seen in my lifetime anything
where it just shut everything no one's
driving anywhere but the point being
what that did was what the pandemic did
for all of us was it it validated that
what we've been teaching
and
so
the big deal jason is this what we teach
you about money works it's the only
system for money
that works in good times and bad times
there are some systems that work only in
bad times and some systems like yours
that work only in good times see debt
only works when debt works when
everything works out the way it's
supposed to perfect that's when it works
but but what it does do is is when your
stupid is stress tested
and when things aren't going good and
stress comes along you're stupid it'll
you'll go oh my god that's stupid and
you weren't it didn't look stupid
whenever everything's going good stupid
can feel smart
because you're not measuring risk and i
know i've done it i've done it with big
zeros on the end so um i mean how can it
go wrong to buy a rental property if the
renter pays your end
until the renter doesn't pay the rent
and then you still have the rental
property oh by the way not only do they
not pay the rent they go into chapter
13. oh worse than that they're going to
chapter 7. so it's four months before
the federal injunction about you
contacting your
debtor as a creditor you're it's illegal
for you to contact your tenant in any
way while they're in chapter seven until
the court gives you permission
and it can be three four months before
you can even contact them so now where's
your renter that pays the rent so you're
stupid just got stress tested
and it was revealed the cracks the
fissures
in the in the the earthquake the in the
plate tectonic plates shifted and boom
you get caught and you're like one of
those dinosaur movies you fall into the
volcanic crater the volcanic crater you
know so beware of that so jason we would
tell you yes i would keep flipping cars
but only with cash and that means you
got to get rid of these two
wow we weren't unclear with that we
weren't too rough no that wasn't too
rough right there it could have been
could have been rougher
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host george
campbell ramsey personality host of the
fine print on ramsey networks one of our
popular podcast series is uh here with
me today to answer your questions about
your career about your relationships
your mental health about your money
we're here to help with your life open
phones at
825-5225 that's triple eight eight two
five five two two five
alma is with us in san jose california
hi elma how are you
hi good dave thank you so much for
taking my call i really appreciate it
can i just say thank you
you've given me a lot of hope and
because of you
i have four hundred thousand dollars in
investments eighteen thousand dollars an
emergency fund
um
um
yeah but i've got a question for you
well thank you elm hey listen let's just
be real clear though i didn't give you
any money it's because of you that that
money's there i'm proud of you you're a
hero
right it was your book let me makeover
that gave me a lot of hope so thank you
so much and i was um i cleared off ten
thousand dollars in debt so you're
amazing
thank you thank you so i've got a
dilemma though because it hasn't really
been perfect um my husband and i have a
home that's worth about a little over a
million dollars
we owe six hundred thousand dollars on
the home
i
i don't think i could do it in seven
point three years
um i'm 53 my husband
will be 73 and i told him i said
sweetheart maybe what we could do is
since your kids live in san diego
maybe perhaps we can purchase a home
there outright when we sell this home
um and so i wanted to know what your
thoughts were on that
so you have four hundred thousand
dollars in equity right now
uh yeah
okay you're moving to san diego why
because his children are there and then
you know he's 73 and you've got
grandkids and
to be like them are you retired or both
of you not
working i'm working he's retired
um but he just he just started working
because
um i said sweetheart you know we
we just need to make things work here if
um what are you going to do are you
going to be able to take your job with
you to san diego
um i'm looking
i may
what do you make
right now i make 85 000 a year okay
well i mean if you can move to another
city
be near family make the same amount of
money and end up in a paid for house all
in the process
i don't know what the downside would be
can you find a property for four hundred
thousand dollars in san diego yeah
i don't know yeah you can
i don't know
it's it's it's below average price but
you can
yeah the average price in san diego is
about a half million right now
um
wow
i mean that's average meaning that
there's
a lot above a lot median house price
half above half below
um i guess the reason why i'm hesitant
is because it's my family home that we
both bought together and it would be
given up my family home
but
it's just been
giving me a lot of anxiety you know um
so
your family home that you grew up in is
where you live now
yes
okay yeah that would be uh
that'd be nostalgic it could be kind of
sad
yeah
yeah but i don't think that um
you know here's the thing i i
it's a trade-off then you know you get
to live with no debt you get to live
near his kids
um
and the the downside is is that you go
through the emotions of the family home
moving on right
yeah exactly yeah and there's gonna be a
lot of grease there
yeah yeah and you know and you get rid
of the anxiety that's associated when
you get rid of the anxiety and i could
do the get free screen
well you can do that anyway you're dead
free except the house so we allow both
kinds of debt-free screams but uh either
way so yeah i i i don't see the only
route now and i actually have a reason
not to do it i didn't see any before and
that's the family home that's new
information late in the conversation
sentimental but i think this is going to
set you up to where if you're if you've
got the only income there and you have
no mortgage payment you're going to be
so free yeah it's going to be amazing i
think it's a good idea to stop though
and say hey things that are sentimental
or valid
this is personal finance
then what you have to do is you have to
weigh
how sentimental it is versus the benefit
on the other side let me give you an
example
lady called in one time she said i have
a wedding ring that i can sell for ten
thousand dollars my wedding ring
and we could pay off ten thousand
dollars worth of debt
and uh how much do you make hundred
twenty thousand a year how much debt do
you have fifty thousand bucks i'm like
no
because you're not going to get that
ring back
you know and that's all it didn't
you know it didn't completely if you
could sell it for a million dollars
thinking about it
you know it was ten thousand bucks yeah
and they make money and the ratio to
their debt to me it wasn't worth the
trade-off i would not sell my wife's
wedding ring even if she wanted to
for ten thousand dollars in that
situation you see what i'm saying
so sometimes sentimental does out does
trump it yeah
not always but sometimes is there a time
where there's a false sentimentality
around it like well this is just my car
i had when i was in high school even
though i got dead you know is there a
moment where you have to be an adult and
say
all right there's some things like that
i mean and you know what i tell people
today is well it was my dad's your dad's
what
john deere tractor i mean you know i
mean what is what are you being
sentimental about you got your dad's old
bible yeah okay that's an heirloom
that's an heirloom versus but somehow
the tractor or i've had pickup trucks my
dad's a pickup truck you know uh uh you
know i wish i had my grandpa's old
pickup truck though oh god it was so
cool
but um three on the tree baby but um you
don't even know what that is i know i
mean this is beyond my shift on the on
the oh
i've seen those up on the yeah yeah they
don't make sense they don't that's
what's called three on the tree now
there's like a button you just press
it's real weird i don't like those i
don't even i don't want to talk about it
sorry um yeah there's a little knob you
just turn it to reverse and now you plug
it into a cord dave's getting very upset
vehicles
you just turned we were having a good
discussion i'm sorry i did that
but this is it's a valid point because
it's personal finance and it's okay to
have feelings about this stuff what
you've got to do is weigh out where is
it taking me and what is the weight
of the item and what's the impact it has
you know if i had grandpa's truck and i
could sell it for four thousand dollars
i'd never sell it in a million years if
i grandpa's truck and i could sell it
for 40 million it's gone
gone so there is a weight to the
sentimentality right
you know 40 million it's gone there's no
such thing sure but but i mean my point
is
everything does have a price in that
sense it's not it's this idea that
you're supposed to that you're
irresponsible if you use any emotions or
sentimentality at all when analyzing
things no you're irresponsible if you
don't you should have those involved
that's my point yeah we're human beings
we got feelings it's personal
finance
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Applause]
a lot happening around ramsay this week
dr john deloney's new book
has gone on pre-sale
it's absolutely incredible be sure and
check it out at ramseysolutions.com also
he and rachel
cruz my daughter will be doing the money
and marriage event this coming friday
night money is one of the biggest
sources of stress for married couples
sharon and i dealt with our fair share
of money stress and i know how heavy it
can be
about 33 years ago
we've been married almost 40 our
marriage was hanging on by thread we
went through bankruptcy and that's when
i set out to learn the right way of
managing money and building wealth
valentine's day instead of an ordinary
date night
put them into the money stress to your
marriage valentine's day sale includes
all kinds of gifts that'll strengthen
your marriage
you can do the money and marriage event
this coming friday night you can check
that out we've got questions for humans
conversation cards
for couples you can get 55 conversation
starters there we've got the wedding
pack for newlyweds and engaged couples
all kinds of different
fun valentine's day things you can do
but this coming friday night be sure and
check out the money and marriage live
stream all of this is going on for
valentine's day right here at
ramseysolutions.com
be sure and check it out mary is with us
in richmond virginia hi mary welcome to
the ramsey show
hey dave i am so so glad i made it
through to you um
i'll just start real quick seven years
ago i remember talking to you and you
told me to put my big girl panties on
and i'm gonna tell you i grew up a lot
whoa
um so when i called and talked to you
about getting myself focused on what i
needed to take care of and not worry
about everybody else so okay
anyway
um since then um
my husband uh passed away um october 3rd
oh my gosh here
what happened
it was actually glioblastoma brain tumor
that a lot of men get uh women and
children get it too but a lot of men
don't realize they have it until it's
too late and there's no cure for it oh
my goodness um
so um
personality changes and that kind of
thing but who tells you when you know
you start blaring off that you need to
go have an mri
yeah um
so
chemo and radiation didn't help it just
extended life that kind of thing
um
i became a a quick caregiver but thank
you dave
all right so here's here's my that's the
back story so
i've got i'm a woman of faith and uh one
thing i can tell you is the
house that we bought
um
my husband at first told me mary you've
got to sell this house it was over 2 800
square feet or 20 any anyway it was it
was a big house and um
and then as he got sicker he was like no
you can't leave well i prayed about it a
lot the kids didn't want to come stay
with me they live in the city in
richmond
um
and i said no
if i'm gonna do this i'm gonna do it now
because the way the market's going
so i um i sold the house
um i sold majority of everything in it
i just kept a few things
um
i bought the home at 276 in 2017
um realtor told me to sell it at one
price and i kept saying no i can get
more for it and i sold it for 379
thousand
wow
i um came out of it with 105 000 in my
pocket after all fees were paid
um which leads me to you now um
i have um
i've paid off over uh seven thousand
almost eight thousand dollars with the
debt that i
had uh yes i do have three credit cards
but there i can pay them off they're
just stupid stupid things that i that i
had
um
totaling only 747 dollars
i have put
uh
uh 58 000 is just sitting in the
checking account
i'm getting it within a credit union are
you working i
i am i am a
paralegal where you live in a makeover
in richmond virginia no i mean what are
you living in now that you sold the
house
oh yeah sorry
um i am actually when i sold the house
my daughter and her new husband told me
i can come stay with them until
my apartment comes open on february 18th
okay okay
so you move in you move into an
apartment next week to rent yep and you
make how much you do that you make how
much a year i make 67 000. okay and
you're going to cut up your credit cards
tonight dadgummit you know that
and um and i have a side gig of twenty
thousand dollars that's right that i
cleared last year so you can you can
make a living and you have
90 to 100 grand laying around
yeah okay so you park it you park it
until you get ready to re-buy
okay that's okay that that okay that's
why i called you because i'm i was
thinking okay
i'd like to get a piece of rental
property no cater to the nerd visiting
nurses okay
okay okay
i want you i want you to stop
okay and you haven't had time to cry yet
yeah you've been just running
from one thing to another that's all
i've ever done you sold your house you
moved you're frenetic everything's going
crazy and you you know how long were
y'all married
34 years yeah
you need to spend about a year
we were a rock and roll couple yeah you
need to spend about a year crying
and you don't need to work on nothing
else just go to work
come home hug your babies hug your
grandbabies if you got any
and see everybody eat dinner with
friends
drink wine and cry
yeah
it's okay and that's one thing i can't
say grateful that the kids weren't there
at the house during that time before i
sold the house because i was able to
grieve a lot yeah i know but
my point is you're still running in
circles a little bit after all this
extreme tragedy
and i want you to have a little bit of
room to grieve and breathe without
having to make a big decision on this
and you certainly crap don't need a
rental property in the middle of all
this
it's a nightmare i mean you're just
asking you're asking for more crap to
deal with i want you to make your life
simple clean quiet
and then out of that healing you're
going to make a whole different decision
in the spring of 23 as to what you do
i've never done that dave it's time i've
never just not done anything it's time
and you're not gonna not do anything for
the rest of your life you're not not
gonna do anything for one year
one year
slow down get rid of that debt get that
emergency fund you're going to sleep so
good at night not having to worry about
a flurry of activity that you've been
keeping yourself busy with it's okay to
just be quiet grieve slowly and you've
got a pile of money that makes it a
whole lot less stressful don't touch it
get on a budget so that you're living on
what you make don't spend any of that
money on anything
set it aside i put it i put majority of
it into a money market and just put like
12 000 into my technique don't don't
touch it you know don't touch it you
don't you don't need any of it right
just don't don't don't get the idea you
need to buy something you don't need to
buy anything
stop okay stop
and i am driving a dave ramsey car
you'll be okay for a year
it'll be okay for you thank you thank
you so much guys if it breaks you can
fix it but i mean just calm
calm
you're then a year from now you go get a
better car figure out how much you want
to set aside for that set aside how much
you want to do for the down payment on a
house buy you a home to live in or a
condo to live in where you stabilize
your housing situation you don't want to
be a renter in perpetuation because you
lost your husband at your young age
that's not that's not the plan
but uh and a renter while you have
renters oh
i don't know it's interesting dave every
time someone has a traumatic event
happen our advice is first before
anything is just slow down we don't need
to make any decisions today or the next
few months we're just going to take a
pause especially when there's a big pile
of money involved and things can get out
of hand when you know emotions are in
there we're starting to spend we're
starting to make decisions while we're
trying to grieve it's just too much at
once yeah well i mean i
i've been married 40 years she's been
married 34 years something happened to
sharon
i mean i i'm not my brain does not work
for a while
and i've got a pretty good brain yeah
but it's not going to work for a while
in that fog
and um
and i told her the other day if she
leaves i'm going with her so um how did
she take it she said she said well you
have to catch me but i've been catching
her for 40 years so it's okay but the uh
uh
i mean the idea that that you can just
you know you're the same as before that
you you need to give yourself room
all of us do it's a human being thing if
you have the financial luxury and she
does
to not make decisions big decisions
quickly then don't make them quickly
just go slow there's no urgency here go
slow
go slow give yourself time for the fog
to clear you're right george that's
that's good
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage levi and sadie are with
us hey guys how are you hey dave welcome
welcome where do you guys live wyoming
all right well welcome all the way to
nashville and here to do a debt-free
scream how much have you paid off 64
000. good for you and how long did that
take took four years and six months
one year that was a bachelor before i
got married so okay
i really uh
looked at that uh
just the report um kind of your
where you're paying interest
and uh that first year i was like man if
i could just throw a bunch at this right
now
it's gonna save me a lot of interest
okay so you got started early and then
you guys get married three years into
the process or one year into the process
been married three years
yep okay good so what was your range of
income during this four years and six
months our monthly budget is based on uh
36 to 48 000 now
cool what do y'all do for a living i own
and operate my own uh mowing grass and
plowing snow oh good for you yep and i'm
a bookkeeper all right very good good so
what kind of debt was the 64 000 it was
our house whoa
[Applause]
you paid off your house what's your
house worth uh the realtor just said
from all the people moving into wyoming
it just bumped up to 350 000. wow
look at you
i love this
well done
well done you guys amazing good work
good work how old are you guys i'm 32.
i'm 26. getting paid
what's up with all these young people
paying off their house dave i don't know
george you like it i told you george 32
paid for a house man i'm seeing a trend
here that's incredible you guys are
awesome so what's the story here
four years six months ago you wanted to
be extra weird yeah i uh
i uh didn't really go to college or
anything and so i just saved money and
then actually in 2007 or something i
heard dave on the radio i went talked to
my parents
i was like who's this dave guy maybe i
should take my college fund since i'm
not really going to go to college
and put it in uh gross talk mutual funds
or something and they're like they kind
of were on the larry burkett train a
little bit so they raised me to
to save money but then i think 2011 i
finally was like you know what i'm if i
go to college i'm gonna you know
just pay for it
so i was able to put a little bit of my
college fund away and then
i was able to put 40 down on on the
house wow it was a foreclosure all the
pipes were frozen frozen so
you guys do all the work yes wow i had a
feeling you were a handy guy
so and my family and friends and
sadie is just the most amazing person
she never complained
we got married and we didn't even have a
kitchen
we used a second bathroom for our
kitchen oh my goodness
cooking is exciting that's the next
level it was an adventure but you are 32
with a paid for 350 000 house yeah
uh yeah you're a little weird and it
paid off yeah i like it i like weird
people good stuff man way to go guys
you're heroes yeah how's it feel to be
your age with a paid for house well we
look at the house very differently now i
think like it's ours i think it's
actually made me maybe a little uh
lazier
i'm like i don't have i don't have to
really pay anybody i'm just let's go
play golf today
[Laughter]
seasonal work i'm like take the winters
off only when it's snowing so luckily we
were able to come out here because we
didn't have snow in the forecast this
week oh okay all right yeah you want to
work yeah
good for you guys well done amazing all
right what do you tell guys oh no i just
wanted to know with you with your
landscaping business do you still mow
your own grass now that you haven't paid
for a house not as much as i mow other
people's grass okay
[Laughter]
uh all right so what do you tell people
the key to getting out of that is uh the
key for me is you gotta love what you're
doing
uh anybody out there right now if you
just hate your job hate going to work
maybe you should this is america find
something you love to do i really enjoy
serving older people mowing their grass
and
um just
doing that every day and um the second
key
having family support you and having a
wife that's with you and
she's just when she just she never
nagged me about the house we were living
in we fixed it up
so that's huge it worked out in the end
yeah
i still got another laundry i still got
a laundry room in the bathroom to finish
remodeling so okay well you always need
a project you need to get with that i
mean come on no laziness get get it done
come on man this woman's putting up with
you get this done
so did you guys have a lot of
cheerleaders in this process were they
looking at you like what are you doing
man you guys are so young oh no we had
lots of cheerleaders um my parents
taught me dave ramsey all growing up so
from ever since i was little i remember
listening to you and um they live
your principles and so it was very much
just natural for me to also do that as
well so wow yep my my mom she's always
encouraging me uh you guys are doing
great and then
one thing my dad he told me when i was a
teenager young guy he said
you know i'm never i'm not going to give
you anything but i'll help you fix
whatever you bring uh to me he's a
diesel mechanic and he's also done
carpentry so i've taken that to i've
taken advantage of him a lot good like
hundreds of thousands of dollars just
he's helping me fix up the house help me
fix equipment so yeah that's how that's
right
well that's a good way to give that's
awesome very cool and he's participating
in you doing smart stuff yeah
so uh so
you know sadie's a financial peace baby
and your mom and dad are larry burkett
followers and larry was in a sense one
of my mentors and it was a friend before
he passed and so uh pretty cool stuff
there it's a one-two punch i love it
very well done good job you guys great
work great work
all right we have a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you that is the next
chapter in your story to be
millionaires for sure you're well on
your way 350 000 are paid for house
that's uh that's the direction you're
going without a doubt and um also a copy
of total money makeover for you to give
to someone and help them get on their
journey and you brought the kiddo with
you what's the name and age this is
reason and uh he's a year and a half all
right and we also have one on the way
all right
very good
very good have we done a gender reveal
yet do we know what it is we don't know
quite yet only like two more weeks oh
okay cool very good well congratulations
you guys what a great life you've got
what a great life you've built for
yourselves i'm proud of you very well
done levi and sadie and rhys recent
he'll shine in wyoming 64 000 paid off
in four years or six months making 36
000 to 48 000 a year a paid for house
and everything at 32 years old worth 350
000 count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one
[Applause]
might need to buy a new mic after that
he might have blown it out and reason
never flinched
that's incredible you got a lot this is
proof more is caught than taught both of
their parents
decided to live by these principles and
they saw that happen and they went i
want to do that that's a good way to
live we are
really uh reaching the point that we're
seeing anecdotally and i guess we need
to quantify these these second and even
third generation
followers of these principles
my grandma and dad my grandma did dave
ramsey that's next
ramsay that'll make you feel real old
though well i'm already older my
great-granddad did it
too late i'm there yeah margarita no he
didn't he's not i'm not
back in the 60s he was listening to you
dave yeah
that's what it's going to be
well now the 2000s are vintage to this
generation so that's scary depends on
the generation but you're right you're
right but it's cool to see i think we
should do a study on this as we get more
of these financial peace babies well
that's how these baby step millionaires
are happening yeah is these guys are
starting at this age and now i mean we
didn't ask in their case but a lot of
these people with doing a debt free
screen whether their 30s
40s 50s when they pay off their home
that usually if you combine it with
their retirement account makes them have
a net worth of over a million dollars
and they've baby stepped their way into
being a millionaire yeah and that's how
the whole baby steps millionaires
projects makes me so excited
imagine kids in their 20s avoiding
college debt paying off their homes in
their 30s becoming baby steps
millionaires in their 40s and they have
40 50 years to live and give like no one
else well and that million will become
10 maybe 20 million over that other next
few decades we could change the world
man that's cool really can and uh create
a generosity movement like never before
we could we could all give so much that
we can make the government irrelevant oh
come on let's go
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host this hour open phones at eight
eight two five 825-5225
james is with us in louisiana hi james
welcome to the show
hey dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
um
the job i'm currently working at is uh
it's a construction site we're building
a uh a power plant
and the job is going to be over
in uh
like in the summertime like june or july
august something like that like that
and so i found your
your book and everything about a week or
so ago
and i paid a credit card down to about
700
and then stopped and started thinking
maybe i should be saving my money
um
just in case uh
something happens and i don't find
another job
before this job
ends
so i was calling to see what you thought
if you think i should keep paying debt
down
or stop and save money until i find
another job what do you make james
i make about 70 000 a year awesome and
how much debt do you have total
twelve thousand credit cards
about five thousand
in uh
student loans
nine thousand and
uh a car line okay
and what what are the chances you're
saying that this could this could all
come to an end in the summer time
how likely is that to happen
it is going to come together for sure
it's very likely it's one of those
they build the plan and then it's done
and well last time this happened last
time this happened how long did it take
you to get a job
a couple of months but that was that was
a few years ago what do you do next job
i swapped directly i am a i t guy
i t
yes what does an it guy do on a
construction site help me with
that uh
well there's a
there's a group of individuals that are
not um computer savvy
and
so i help them out with
their computer issues and things of that
nature in their phones and
everything like that so you could be an
i.t guy anywhere
absolutely it's not construction related
necessarily it's i.t related
correct yes yes sir okay
all right would you want a salaried
position that's full time somewhere
yeah that was i mean
why don't you go and look for a job now
yeah what's the harm in just starting to
look
no i've definitely been looking for
a few months
how much money do you have in savings
uh about
fifteen hundred dollars okay
so we got baby step one more but
yeah well i'll use some of it to pay
down
one of the credit cards so all right so
the answer the answer to your question
is you have a storm coming
and you're saying how much
how much food do i set back for this
hurricane that's coming
right and uh how much does it take to
survive it well what we have is we have
a predicted storm
sometimes they come sometimes they don't
we know that so
so what i would do is i would stop
everything i pay off that little 700
card and cut that up but after that i'd
start piling up cash and then go get a
job
when you get a job the storm is passed
you know because the the uncertainty the
risk is over
right so go get a job now you don't have
to wait till august
is there some kind of big payout at the
end
you know
the main thing is i
about a year ago i went and got a degree
i went back to school and got a degree
in a different field
so i'm really trying to swap to that
field oh what's that feel first career
out
um
it's uh
like a production like an operator
the people that work at the plant and
makes the make whatever products
um usually like a refinery
making plastics and
silica and stuff like that
so you want to move into that field
instead of i.t have you looked into
those jobs in your area or would you
have to move yes
uh there's there's jobs all around here
it's just a matter of um
which i've been doing applying and
uh going on interviews and
good okay when you get that okay so the
answer question is pilot money until you
get this job situation solved
okay you got to have you got to have the
new job going forward because until then
we have a whole a potential hole
in august that you could fall into
but if you if you if you figure it out
before august and you get the new job
then don't wait take all of that money
and start working the baby steps
okay and go get the job don't screw
around wait on august it'll be here in
about 30 seconds i want you to have a
fire under your feet
well i do okay i've dealt with it before
where i had no job and got laid off and
it's
it's not very much fun yeah it's less
than fun so let's pile up as much cash
as we can and get the new job then take
that cash and start your debt snowball
with that start your start push play on
your total money makeover baby steps at
that point but that's exactly what you
do hold on we're going to give you a
copy of ken coleman's new book from
paycheck to purpose it's got some real
insights on helping you land
the job of your dreams the career of
your dreams and it'll help so hang on
we'll have you have that sent to you
bear is with us in seattle hey bear
welcome to the ramsay show
thank you sir
how are you doing today better than i
deserve man what's up
not much i've got
a little situation with my wife trying
to get our family straightened out
uh
just to be honest i've been sorry bear
speak directly into your phone for us
we're having a hard time hearing you is
this all right that's better
we'll try and give it a go sorry let's
get my baby set up with some snacks
um
i have
been overly controlling with her
finances in the past uh may have caused
her a little bit of financial trauma
just from
uh i know she's a very anxious person so
i tried to help by taking money out of
her
concerns
but i don't think that helped at all and
listening to the show for a little bit
obviously
uh secrets is not a good thing and i
think
laying out a budget and having her
you know contribute towards that is the
best way to do it but i got the
free uh you know every dollar app and
try to set up a budget with her
but she's kind of zoned out didn't want
to listen to
or contribute to the financial
conversation i'm curious where to go
from here
so she
she's anxious about the finances but she
doesn't want to look at it either
yeah and i think that's where probably
my history hasn't helped out with a lot
of this um how much of this is the
trauma from you controlling it and she's
going hey i don't want to deal with this
guy
well i don't think it's like she doesn't
want to deal with me she's got a lot on
her plate we're coming out of a real cup
season
what's the other side
uh she's in nursing school because she's
doing that full-time
you don't have help with child care so i
am
working like night so we just don't see
each other a lot we're both working like
eight hour weeks what it feels like
well have you guys talked about your
your financial goals together
a little bit the only thing i didn't
know that she really aspires to is
building a house
um someday and so that's kind of what i
was trying to set up
um i just i'm honestly not sure how to
get there from where we're at
um
um yeah so that's the biggest thing
we're gonna focus on pulling that out we
should have it done in a couple of
months um we got credit cards debt-free
and the last thing is our student loan
we got about
seven thousand dollars on that
and we should be able to get that
cleared in the next several months okay
let me tell you i i
you you've got to uh separate the
distractions you can turn off the
stinking television put the kid to bed
and the two of you sit down together
quietly
and set some goals
and you draw her into the conversation
with questions
rather than statements
and just say all right honey how do you
think we're gonna get there what do you
think we ought to do about this we're
not going to do this anymore without
your vote counting as much as my vote
counts i know i've been controlling in
the past and i know you've been absent
in the past neither one of us are going
to do that anymore we're both going to
be here as two grown-ups we're gonna sit
here calmly and maturely we're gonna
make decisions about our future and we
both have a vote
if you guys can't pull that conversation
off
you don't have a money or a budgeting
problem you have a marriage problem that
you'll need to sit down with a marriage
counselor that's what's going on and
bear i want to give you guys a ramsay
plus subscription for a year go through
the financial peace university videos
and we'll give you every dollar plus
which will connect to your bank
hopefully that gets you guys on the path
both of you together go through them
together you've done enough separate
already
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us america it's a free call at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five george campbell ramsey personality
host of the fine print and also host of
the entree leadership podcast two of our
ramsey network podcasts that are very
popular is my co-host today as we answer
your questions about your relationships
your money your careers your life thanks
for joining us again triple eight eight
two five five two two five charlie's in
phoenix hey charlie how are you
i'm doing good thanks for asking i
appreciate that sure how can we help um
so i have a question
i retired like three years ago at 60
and um
i'm i'd probably have like
about 1.8 million dollars
in investments and i only have the only
property i have is the house which paid
off i've been deaf for you probably for
10 years probably
um well my question is is like that
anxiety because i've been a saver all my
life
and i still have a hard time i mean i
have a
like a side gig that i make about i know
13 to 14 000 a year at
over a few months out of the year
and um i just want to know what your
thoughts are how to get over that hump
that i can spend the money that i have
sitting in
401ks uh mutual funds um and an
investment count
are you single charlie are you married
i am married for my me and my my wife
and i have been there 39 years awesome
we have three kids and 16 grandkids wow
that's great
there's one place to spend all that
money on those grandkids
that's incredible yeah well i do that
and
you try to anyway
are you pulling an income off of your
mutual funds yet
no i'm not taking any money out of my
mutual funds
or my 401ks or anything i have like i
have about two
about three hundred thousand dollars in
in a money market account and um
emergency fund type what do you live on
where do i live line yeah what do you
what do you pay your monthly expenses
with
it's not thirteen thousand
i
yeah i pay about
i use my money market account and the
money that i get from my side gig
that i like i said i make about 13 to 14
000 a year doing that and what do you
spend how much of your money market a
year are you using a year
um i don't know
not very much i'm i'm still in that
saving moment behind the couch i'm like
i don't know if i want to spend the adam
you know but
what does your wife think about this
does your wife work outside the home no
we're both retiring but she retired
before i did
okay
all right so you're stopping
you're being confusing as crud all right
you're not living on thirteen thousand
dollars a year
so where is the rest of the money coming
from that you are living on are you
draining the money market slowly
you're not living on twenty thousand
dollars a year i get it that you're a
saver but you're not living on that
um
yeah we live on about twenty five
thousand no you don't what's your
property taxes on your house
700
a year
yeah wow what's the house in phoenix
arizona what do you live in well no no i
live
our house is worth about three hundred
thousand dollars
and i live in a small community out
about 35 miles outside of things i live
in a place called san tan valley okay
and your property taxes on 350 house or
700 grand or seven hundred dollars yeah
sure
you had seven to eight hundred dollars
something like that
okay yeah something like that
and it's just that it's 1800 square feet
we downsized from
a two-story
house and
and now we have all right the difference
in larry burkett used to say that the
difference between saving and hoarding
is attitude
it's attitude it's not an amount
okay
and the fact that you are unable to
enjoy any of this wealth that you have
built
and you are living on
below the poverty level with your income
while you have a millionaire in the bank
is that that's whacked you you do need
to work on this
okay okay yeah so i want you to get with
me i want you to get with your
investment advisor and i want you to
start drawing
60 000 bucks a year 80 000 bucks a year
and i want you to take your wife on a
nice trip and i want you to buy her a
purse that makes your hair curl
and i want you to
buy a nice car
you have two million dollars young man i
mean my goodness gracious you are
amazing you have done a great job but
your muscles you only developed one of
the three muscles needed to handle money
the saving and investing muscle you did
not develop the generosity muscle and
you did not develop the enjoyment muscle
and i don't want you to spin to the
point you go broke and i'm not
suggesting that you become a spin thrift
i'm freaking dave ramsey i'm known for
being a tight wad okay but but but you
you've got to uh you know
psychologically spiritually emotionally
relationally get to the point you enjoy
this you don't want your grandkids
memory of you to be a guy that piled up
all the money in the corner and no one
ever saw it you stood in front of it and
protected the money
you want your grandkids to remember a
grandpa that was kind and generous and
wise
and thoughtful
and thought about the future
and also enjoyed the present
yeah i will tell you that when i first
retired in our money market account
we probably had about
350 000 in it
you spent 50 grand 50 grand in three
years
you're out of control and being
sarcastic okay
yeah i i know are you hearing what i'm
saying dude
yeah i know i need to change my attitude
you've got to enjoy this money and
here's the thing let me tell you how you
built a millionaire you used a system
didn't you you're a systems guy
yes okay so you need to say
i'm going to allocate this number of
dollars to this category to spend
and then work the system go
spend it you've got to build the
enjoyment muscle i don't want you to be
out of control i'm not asking you to be
irresponsible i'm not asking you to be
unwise
but uh you you're you you called because
you know you're out of balance
you know that that's muscle that this
muscle of enjoyment and the generosity
muscle are both weak
and so
uh yeah i want you to go give every
grandkid 500 bucks
all the youtube comments right now are
saying hey i know one place you can send
it charlie here's my venmo
but sir you need to sit down with your
wife go to a really nice dinner get a
nicest steak you can and write down all
the goals allocate percentages towards
giving and spending and then go do it
and force yourself i'd like for you to
go on when cruises open back up go on a
cruise around the world and spend more
than you spent all of last year and take
the whole family
20 000 bucks out of a millionaire you're
gonna be okay man
you're gonna be okay as well you live
like no one else so that later
you can live and give like no one else
you gotta play that last part out
charlie that's what it was for it's not
for piling it up and looking at the pile
of money this is the ramsey show
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free
whitepaper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
[Music]
if you've been paying attention to the
real estate market you've noticed
competition out there is high in part
because available inventory has been low
not a lot of houses for sale compared to
the number of buyers looking when
inventories low it simply means there
are more buyers buying than sellers
selling means the pressure's turned up
buyers want to snag the right house
sellers want to get the right offer this
is not amateur hour
this is the time to have a pro in your
corner to win in this type of market you
need a pro by your side whether you're a
buyer or a seller
and that's why we find vet and endorse
top real estate agents across the
country called endorsed local providers
to help you buy or sell our agents have
years of industry success and refuse to
compromise your financial goals no
matter how tough the competition is
good news is you can instantly connect
with an endorsed local provider in your
area today go to ramseysolutions.com
agent and find a ramsey trusted
elp agent near you that's ramsey
solutions dot com
slash
agent
so george have you ever heard that rich
people are evil i hear it all the time
that the only way to get rich is to be
evil
and steal
and be a crook
well if you made money you did it off
the you know it you made it dirty you
had to because everyone knows
capitalists are all evil
then you guys are getting the sarcasm my
help out there but um i've been on
twitter i know what happens over there
yeah oh why does anybody go on twitter
anymore it's ridiculous but anyway the
uh
uh
the truth however as we dig into it
millionaires
decca millionaires 10 million or more
and billionaires
uh have about the same ratio of jerks
among them as poor people
the percentage of people who are crooks
is pretty much just the same percentage
of people who are crooks
and so what we find is the vast majority
of wealthy people
became wealthy by being good people not
by being bad people
so we decided we're going to have a
greedy rich people segment every so
often oh i like that we want to feature
some greedy rich people today we're
going to feature greedy dolly parton
everyone knows how greedy dolly is she's
a horrible person
at dolly's theme park dollywood she's
announced that they will begin paying
college tuition for all
of their employees
they'll want to go to school of course
they'll be covering 100 of college costs
if you work there which includes fees
and textbooks this amazing benefit will
be available to all employees on their
very first day of work it's available
for seasonal part-time and full-time
employees at dollywood parks and resort
dolly you're just evil i can't believe
how evil you are dave careful someone's
going to clip just that sentence out and
they're going to say dave ramsey hates
dolly that's never happened to me george
now let's take something out of context
just the latest wholesale wholesome
improvement dolly car partners made for
the lives of those around her the iconic
country music star has shown time and
time again that she's dedicated to her
community she gave millions of dollars
and raised millions of dollars for the
fires when the gatlinburg fires happen
she has run a free book program for
children in the state of tennessee for
decades uh that evil rich person dolly
pardon we salute you
we love to hear it that's incredible i
don't know that i've seen something at
this level of evil at this level there's
a lot of evil we should not be sending
people to school debt-free like this we
should not be good to our employees wow
because corporations are never good to
their employees corporations are buying
and
automatically evil just because you said
corporation
that does have a connotation to it i
have a relative that goes it's the
corporations it's the corporations like
like it's some kind of thing i don't
know what that means i'm a corporation i
don't know what this means it's fuel
corporations it's the corporation you
gotta have someone to blame for your
problems dave and rich people are a
great problem great one to blame yeah
well it's easy to blame things until you
actually know people
you know one way you do away with sexism
racism
and um what do you call this wealthism
ooh i like that is you actually get to
know
those people
that
fall in those categories and then voila
it's very difficult to hate them that's
true it's very difficult to think they
are lesser it's hard to hate generations
lesser than human if you if you really
want to if you really get to know
someone of a certain
whatever category demographic
very difficult to hate people of that
demographic after that if you really get
to know them because they have dreams
they have goals uh
they have good intentions and the
narrative that someone else wrote about
them
is usually not true
well you know you only you see what you
want to see and that's what happens but
dolly's had a great uh great pr her
personal brand everyone loves dolly no
one doesn't love dolly
but she's greedy rich people that's
right
but look what money can do i mean it's
incredible awful it's horrible that
she's paying tuition for all of those
team members that's the most
unbelievable thing
what what what a waste i might go i just
worked there part time and on day one
just get some tuition go back to school
that's pretty incredible i haven't seen
anything of this scale this is pretty
cool we're a seasonal worker
joking and sarcasm aside but i mean it's
just funny and of course dolly is a
national treasure she's his treasure for
the state of tennessee uh we all love
dolly everybody loves dolly and
not everybody because not everybody
loves anybody in this world today i'm
sure some idiots find a way to hate on
even dolly but um
but oh my gosh do you think this will be
a trend what more and more concretely
rich people segments
we're definitely going to do this over
and over more of these greedy
corporations trying to send people to
school debt-free you think that that
when there might be a trend of us
exposing the fact that corporations are
not all greedy
ding ding ding because corporations are
made up of people
and not all people are greedy
and not all people are evil not all
people are crooks just because they have
money you doofus you're offending a lot
of people right now i hope so it's my
goal
if you believe that stuff you're a
doofus
oh it's unbelievable man
and here's the problem the thing that we
need the reason we need to have the
gritty rich people segment and expose
the greed of all these rich people and
the horrible things that they do in our
society like dolly's doing this horrible
thing here
we need to expose these things because
what rabbi lapin says in his book thou
shall prosper my buddy orthodox jewish
rabbi
daniel lapin it's absolutely so cool
when you get rabbi back on the show it's
been a while and uh but anyway he says
one of the 10 reasons that the jewish
people regardless of the time in history
or the location in geography regardless
of where they show up they have an
inordinate probability of building
wealth greater than the people around
them
and he lists 10 reasons that that
happens for jewish people inside the
book thou shalt prosper which is a great
book by the way i highly recommend that
book one of my faves of all times
one of the reasons is is that they
believe
that the making of money
represents service
and so they believe that the making of
money
is is
a holy endeavor
workship
is very much like worship
in that culture and so the idea that
i believe making money is a holy
endeavor and
i believe it to be highly moral
to
make money
if i'm in that culture now here's the
thing
it is in in psychology dr john dolone
could expand on this but in psychology
we talk about the idea that
cognitive dissonance
when you have something in your brain
that does not align
a belief that does not align with an
action
you cannot live in that in that state
very long you'll adjust either the
belief or the action eventually
and so in other words if you believe
that making money and being wealthy is
evil it is very difficult for you to
make money
and become wealthy
if you believe it's inherently moral
it's in line then there is no cognitive
dissonance and so you have this tendency
this magnetic pull so to speak to
in your psychology and your spirit to go
make money because you believe it to be
a moral act
you know if you believe that uh smiling
is silly you won't smile
but other people believe that if you're
happy you ought to notify your face you
know and that kind of stuff right so
it's this consistency this lack of
cognitive dissonance but and so all you
people running around out there telling
people rich is evil you're spreading a
disease through our culture that keeps
people from wanting and believing that
becoming financially successful is good
therefore they can't do it
and it's really a dangerous hope stealer
thing money's a tool it can do a lot of
good it can do a lot of bad you get to
choose i hope steelers are everywhere
all over and so we're here with the
greedy rich people segment to expose the
greedy rich people
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 thousand dollars about two
years after that i got a remote job that
pays me 130 000 all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your relationships your
mental health
your money
your working careers it's the ramsay
show thanks for being with us open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five
two two five
with us in dallas texas christopher and
molly are here to do a debt-free scream
what's up guys hello
we're so glad to be here well we're
honored to have you how much debt have
you paid off
a hundred and forty eight thousand four
hundred and forty six dollars and thirty
two cents love it how long did that take
we reached around and paid six thousand
on our son's car because we realized i
was co-signing on that too well why not
knock it out i like it all right and uh
how long did all this take a total of 29
months good for you and your range of
income during that time
uh we started at 84 000 and we finished
at 162. whoo
okay let's just go ahead and double our
income in two and a half years how'd you
do that
um molly got a job she she was actually
unemployed for a brief period of time
which is kind of what got this ball
rolling okay cool what do you do molly
i'm a nurse wound care oh well there it
is okay
and uh what about you christopher what's
your position i am a retired naval
officer and i just uh completed your
financial coach master training so i'm
going to move into that all right very
cool very good good for you thank you
for your service
so what started this journey two and a
half years ago
well molly was working in a position
that basically disappeared her
the doctor she was working for decided
he didn't want to be at that hospital
anymore so when he left her job went
with him
and we
kind of panicked a little bit
and her mother um gave her an early
birthday present of
fpu
oh way to go mom
okay
so anxiety and here's how you solve the
anxiety you develop a plan and beat it
yes sir
i like it good very good good for you
guys what kind of debt was the 148
uh about 32 000 was credit card
30 thousand well 36 000 was cars we had
a signature loan for 6 000 and uh air
conditioner loan for 8 600 and then the
rest of 72 000 was student loans oh wow
so you you were normal you had a little
bit everything a little bit of
everything yep yeah normal sucks okay
good for you guys amazing get some debt
potpourri going on there
so you jump into financial peace
university and what happened
well um we we figured out that we were
doing things incorrectly obviously um we
didn't we weren't doing the roles
properly she was the one running the
finances and i was the actual nerd so
when we figured that out and i took over
doing the budgeting and we just started
doing our regular budget meetings that's
when things really started to to happen
so you took over not doing the budgeting
but developing the budget and then the
two of you did the budgeting together
correct okay making sure we're saying
that right yeah is that what happened or
am i putting words in your mouth no
that's that's the way we did it okay we
followed the rules as the free spirit
she was required to change something and
still is to this day i love that
okay you did learn the rules all right i
like it
very good you guys are powerful man how
does it feel you got to feel like like
you got big financial muscles
oh man it's like a complete i mean it
sounds trite but it's it's a it's a
burden lifted off our shoulders for real
yeah
yeah and uh we just we just refinanced
the house to a 15-year fixed and so
that's that's that's our
you know plan with baby steps four we
don't need five because the the kids
college is taken care of with the gi
bill so oh yeah okay
wow that's good how many kids you got
two we got two boys okay very
24 and 21. all right
good for you guys well fun fun fun all
right now you've been through financial
peace university you're getting ready to
be a coach
um you've you're successful you've
actually done it you paid off 148 000
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is
knowing your roles and sticking to them
good yep and that and and you like
everybody says doing the budget i mean
if if if we weren't if we weren't doing
the way we were supposed to be doing it
we were doing it wrong we would we've
never gotten the ball rolling at all i
mean a buddy of mine gave me a copy of
the total money makeover 10 years
earlier
and i came home and i showed tomorrow
hey you need to do a budget
and then i went back to work and so that
was not the right way to do things
and here you are now you went through
fcmt and you're going to coach people
and you have an incredible story to go
hey i did this stuff you can too
yes indeed
awesome we're so proud of you guys
well done what do you tell uh who were
your biggest cheerleaders
definitely our parents um molly sadly
molly's mother passed away um about five
months after we got started and that we
know she's cheering us on from heaven
amen amen and she's the one that gave
you the financial peace kit yes sir oh
wow okay
oh my gosh wow
well this is definitely in her memory
then what was her name absolutely her
name was diane okay
well here's to diane wow wow wow i love
it
well you guys are all charged hopefully
i can get that out without crying no i'm
hear you i hear you i mean i don't blame
you it's it's uh
this whole thing's her fault
exactly
i love it well you guys are rock stars
you took control of your lives
that's a it's very very powerful to see
people do that way to go great job great
job we've got a copy of the baby steps
millionaires for you that's the next
chapter in your story for sure that's
where you're going next uh you're on the
way to doing that you're making serious
money you're killing this
very very very well done and also a copy
of total money makeover you'll be able
to give that away to one of your clients
and um
and disrupt their lives you're going to
be in the disruption business for the
rest of your life doing this financial
coaching stuff the financial coach
master series training that you've been
through so you're in in great shape way
to go guys congratulations
thank you
christopher and molly dallas texas 148
000 plus 6 000 did in 29 months making
84 to 162.
debt-free count it down let's hear a
free scream
three two one we're done
[Applause]
[Music]
love it that is how it's done boys and
girls
oh my goodness
that's so powerful from broke to coach
that's a cool story
you know george the uh
interesting data that we actually do
have data on uh is all the people that
been through financial peace university
we track and the people doing the
debt-free screams we don't keep detailed
on but anecdotally we hear every every
other or every virtually every debt free
screen they say how did you do this they
say the budget now what people don't
realize is there's about a whole bunch
of ways to do a budget and most of them
are wrong
yeah there's really only
he brought up several times that's why i
remember so i thought we'd talk about it
for a second he brought up several times
you have to do it the right way
zero based and a lot of people just
think well i'm just going to write down
what i'm spending well that's not great
just to see what you spend that's that's
a step in the right direction to look in
the mirror but you've got to do a
zero-based budget where your income
minus your expenses equal zero that's
how we teach it and that is the only
right way to do a budget and if you're
married you gotta do it together and
that's what he was talking about we
teach that in financial peace university
usually one person develops the budget
but the other person has got to
contribute it's gotta be a powerful just
change something the free spirit doesn't
like doing the budget the nerd likes
doing it typically but uh uh what they
do love what every couple loves is
learning to work together
and if they don't love working together
they're not a couple there we go so and
so some of them discover that too but um
but here's the thing you know you you
learn to say okay here's our here's
where we're going our big goal
and here's the price we have to pay to
get there what must be true for us to
get there
you know what must be true
i was talking to one of our guys on the
elevator a while ago he's lost 27 pounds
i said how'd you do that he said well i
you know we cut out refined sugar we cut
out all kinds of bread we cut out gluten
um and uh
and dairy that was his thing okay and he
said okay so what must be true to lose
27 pounds in his case was he had to do
that what must be true on a budget is
you say okay in order to get out of debt
so that we can become wealthy so that we
can change our family tree and be
outrageously generous live like no one
else so that later we can live like no
one else what has to be true right now
this week
in the written budget we have to be in
agreement on we're willing to pay that
price to win
and uh when you do that and every dollar
has a name and you're in agreement every
dollar has an assignment that's why our
budgeting app the world's best budgeting
app is called every dollar because every
dollar has an assignment
every dollar has a name and you're in
agreement with your spouse
and both of you are talking about this
every single month if not every single
week while you're doing the plan
that's the right way
to do a budget gives you power it's
amazing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today first peter 4 10
each of you should use whatever gift you
have received to serve others
as faithful stewards of god's grace
in its various forms
henry ford says coming together is a
beginning
keeping together is progress
working together is success oh that's
good i haven't heard that one that's a
good one robert is with us robert's in
cincinnati hi robert welcome to the
ramsey show how can george and i help
uh well i've got a question on investing
and if i could i'll tell you how i got
to this question okay um i would say in
2008 i started listening on the radio
about 2011-12 i was debt-free but broke
effectively
um currently i am maxing out my 401k and
my hsa
i got a little small pension from a
previous company
um
54 now
i'm looking advice on investing
um the one side effect of going debt
free is
i became
reluctant to lose sight of my money
which i've been listening now i feel
like a greedy frugal leprechaun you know
guarding my little pot of
gold so
how big is this pot of gold give us some
numbers
um
my total net worth including house is
probably just under a million okay house
is paid for
yes man you have really done a
turnaround congratulations
uh yes it's just about the decision at
the same time i decided to lose weight i
lost like 150 pounds whoa
well luckily i've only made those two
decisions in my life i don't know if the
third one would be you know
it might turn out bad wow way to go man
awesome congratulations so what's your
question
um
investments
um i've been really reluctant to lose
sight of my money i do low
risk investments
um besides my 401k my hsa i just i got a
lump on the money in the bank that the
interest rate is your 401k and your ssh
hsa are invested in what
um just it's across the board it's
something they do at work so it's
it's i don't know medium risk i guess
okay we'll call it growth stock mutual
funds
yeah
okay and how's that done
relatively well now over over a 10-year
period of time
um over let's say six years yes it's
done well yeah okay
does that not give you some faith
um
a little bit so i mean you could do that
same exact mutual fund
not in a 401k instead of having the
money sitting in your checking account
yes
so how much money is sitting around in
cash right now in savings
probably in the public 300k wow okay
well here's the thing
the the only way that anyone should
invest is they become comfortable
with the investment
emotionally and intellectually
meaning you understand it
okay
so let me give you an example when you
bought that house
um
were you were you laying at wake at
night stressed and wide-eyed i doubt it
worried about that house becoming worth
zero
no okay
uh the the neighborhood that you were
buying in were you familiar with the
neighborhood when you bought that house
no you weren't okay i was not what made
you comfortable buying a house in that
neighborhood
um i had accidentally sold my house
quicker than i thought i was in a rental
house for
a year that's not what i'm asking when
you bought that house in that
neighborhood what made you comfortable
doing that
what made it what made it
it just felt right and when we walked
into the house the house felt right okay
which made you believe
based on just housing
in general you're 50 something years old
you've been you got walking around since
you've walked through areas you say okay
an area that looks like this
in my life experience generally goes
up
right that's kind of what went through
your head i suppose
yeah okay
and so the way i look at any investment
is the same way i look at the
neighborhood the track record of the
neighborhood so if i'm going to buy a
uh a growth and income conservative
growth stock mutual fund that falls in
the growth and income category i can
look at that category of mutual funds
and say okay this neighborhood
you know here's what they've just about
all done there's 68 of them there's 168
of them and here's what they've just
about all done there's some bad ones and
some good ones but most of them kind of
fall right here right and so
and i can look at the stock market in
general and say you know the the stock
market's average annual rate of return
is just under 12 since it started
way back okay or i can look at a mutual
fund that i looked at the other day
that um is over 80 years old
and it only had 15 times in 80 years it
lost any money
a good neighborhood you know what i'm
saying yes and so the track record on
the investment gives you comfort
the history
and so that allows you to lose sight of
your money because here's the thing
in every case you when you put the money
in checking when you put the money in
cds you lost sight of it
it's not in your it's not in cash under
your mattress
you still put it you still put it in
something out of sight you just trusted
it
yeah we're easy access yeah yeah i mean
you got easy access to a mutual fund
i moved some money out of one uh at 10
o'clock this morning and it was in my
account this afternoon
okay
out of a mutual fund today because i was
doing a real estate deal and i just
moved some stuff today
i i jumped online i've got an online
access to it and i just i hit the online
thing and blood showed up in the
checking account you know so i got real
access to it just like more than you do
with a cd because there's no no penalty
for so the point being
i i would sit down with smartvestor pro
and learn yeah i want you to get
comfortable with this and one of those
ways is to be educated and our
smartvestor pros are financial pros
they're going to walk you through this
they're not going to make the decision
for you they're just going to show you
hey this is what this fund has done over
the last 10 to 15 years and you go okay
cool i'll do that one but the thing
you're not thinking about is the risk of
having this money sitting in cash not
even beating inflation i'd be more
stressed about that than i would having
it in a good gross stock mutual fund
that's one of the least risky
investments out there compared to all
this other stuff that you could be in
like single stocks and crypto and who
knows what else and so our advice is
very conservative when it comes to
investing because we want you to get
rich slow yeah so robert when i tell
people to put their mutual funds in
in their retirement and otherwise across
four types growth growth and income and
aggressive growth and
and international i personally do that
i've done that for thirty years
and i have averaged north of twelve
percent
averaged over that period of time on my
money
and uh you might only make ten but it's
a heck of a lot more than checking and
it's a calm neighborhood
there's not a lot of fireworks there's
not a lot of shooting up and down the
street that you know it's it's a
predictable neighborhood and what you've
got to do is just get comfortable with
the neighborhood you got comfortable
with the neighborhood when you bought a
house you got comfortable when you
bought a cd
so reach over here and learn something
about that and get comfortable with the
neighborhood and then start moving some
that way and and just watching it a
little bit closer i don't think you're
doing a bad job i just think as you said
you're kind of doing good and you want
to move towards great
that's what you're looking for without
taking a bunch of risk and without being
rash or crazy or out of control
but mutual funds are not that
complicated there's not that much to
them sit down with the smartvestor pro
someone with the heart of a teacher you
click smart mr pro smartmisterpro
ramseysolutions.com find one in the area
near you it's people we've vetted they
will have the heart of a teacher and
they will give you advice similar to
what you hear here on the show but
you're going to learn about it you're
not going to do it because
that guy said too or cause dave ramsey
said to or george campbell said too
definitely not me for sure but robert i
want to send you a copy of baby steps
millionaires that's dave's number one
national bestselling book and i think it
will give you some comfort to hear the
stories of millionaires who have done
this stuff how they did it it will show
you that you're on the right path and
that you don't need to be as worried as
you as you might think so hang on we're
going to get you a copy of baby steps
millionaires and we're cheering you on
man as you continue your wealth building
journey absolutely george good show
today fun times thank you well done
good show to all you people in the booth
they're we used to try to call their
names there's too many 15 of them in
there there's too many of them and some
of them are on the operating board so
that's right you know there you go
that's how that works
i messed it up one time and i'll never
live it down you're right you won't
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you